don't have a plan B go all in there's no
other alternative please welcome Joel
Kenan I'm going to be the
president you're going to flip me those
[__] controls to me what have
you done to me there's your pep talk
like most people in America my
introduction to you was in The Killing
yo bth how's it hanging and then now
here you are like the hardest working
man in Hollywood like you're all over
the place you have to fall in love with
the craft finding acting gave me this
whole purpose in life and then I would
start getting panic attacks I would
throw up every time before I went on
stage like these [__] demons that are
in my head like these voices that like
[__] me that ruin everything like
what is the worst thing that they could
experience that's where everything
changed if you have that facility to not
shy away from those things then then
you're in this sort of curious growth
mindset way of approaching your life
good conversation did I find my
therapist I'm extremely proud to
introduce you to our newest brand
partner on check out their lineup of
super comfortable sleek and durable
pieces for yourself at
on.com so nice to meet you thanks for
coming out here dude nice to meet you
too yeah um I remember this must have
been maybe three or four years ago I saw
a
video of you like doing some cold
plunging with whm Hoff oh yeah and I
think that was up at was that up at Jeff
cno's Place commune up into panga Canyon
oh okay well yeah cuz I did it a couple
of times we did it at my house once on
my rooftop but then I think that you
might have seen yeah yeah yeah cuz I was
invited to that I know Jeff and he was
like whims here come on up we're going
to hang out and for some reason I
couldn't go go and then I saw those
videos Lou how was there and I was like
damn man cuz I I was really wanting to
meet you and took a couple more years
but but here we are so um this is cool
dude I know that you recently just got
back from jeda right yeah just came back
from Saudi Arabia from the the Red Sea
film festival promoting the movie as was
promoting the movie I was also in the
jury for the film festival there with
BOS lurman bz lurman yeah epic epic man
and what's that guy like in real in real
life is he he just seems like such a
genius artist but also you know that his
presentation is almost a caricature of
like himself you know no no he's like a
living embodiment of his movies I but
he's like he's always on the Move he's
always doing you know in like extremely
fashionable like you know like the
latest fashion he's he's he's a cool cat
um but I I really enjoyed spending the
time with him and and the time that we
got to spend in the jury there cuz it
was we saw some incredible films it was
actually a a really really good
experience being there it was uh like
it's a country where you know movies and
music were illegal six years ago six
years ago women couldn't drive and we
were sitting in a movie theater like an
open theater with you know um it was a
hardcore like Pakistani feminist movie
with like a trans lead
and and we were in the audience with
maybe 30 women that were wearing like
nikab you know where you only see the
eyes and people were like cheering at
the end of the movie and you're just
looking around I was like times are
changing this is cool yeah like a really
really special energy among like young
people and you know women artists yeah
it was it was um it was a pretty
profound experience being there I got to
say I've been to Jetta I've been to a
couple places in Saudi Arabia and
there's few places that you can travel
to where you're like wow like I'm far
from home like it is different here you
know I mean that was a number of years
ago it was probably like
2015 16 something like that I can't
remember closed yeah close Saudi Arabia
very different place now yeah and
there's like a thriving like growing
film like industry there cuz I know
weren aren't you weren't you supposed to
do this Neil Blum Camp movie at like
neom yeah supposed to be shooting it
right now actually wow so they got
bumped I mean hopefully they'll put it
together but uh for for next year but
we'll see yeah the neem thing is wild I
mean the whole their whole like their
whole thing is pretty wild you know also
what they're doing that they're putting
so much into education I mean like kind
of what sets them apart I mean I don't
want to sound like um a part of the
Saudi tourism Bureau like you know spawn
con here yeah yeah they have to pay me a
lot more for that but um no but it's uh
you know they have the population base
to really have these to have a domestic
industry that kind of clashes with the
the outside uh world that's coming in
and um yeah it's uh it it's it's pretty
cool yeah um so you're here mainly
because Silent Night is out yeah this
movie is [__] unhinged dude yeah it
must have been a trip uh to shoot that
movie and I think it's um I mean the
movie's great it like fires on all
cylinders it is you know just this sort
of straight Revenge vigilante you know
story about this guy with the special
Twist of there being like zero dialogue
yeah with the great John Woo who hasn't
made a movie in the US in like 20 years
right um how did that come together I
mean the invitation to like star in a
movie movie by John Woo must have been a
cool experience for you yeah yeah it
definitely
was and then it being paired with you
know sort of being in some ways like a
cinematic experiment you know that
there's not a single line of dialogue in
the movie um so I I wanted to you know
take a you know I started out in as a
theater actor and sort of in Swedish
Cinema and then I moved over here and
and over the course of my career here
I've done more and more action or you
know I've done some action and I enjoy
that that part of it but I always want
to find some action thing that is also
paired with like real drama and and and
a you know a real acting challenge so I
don't feel like that part of it sort of
stagnates and so this you know on its
face really had both of those elements
to get to work with one of the you know
legendary directors of of film and then
also having that element of there's no
dialogue in it and you have to it's just
a I mean it actually it it it was one of
those things that that really taught me
to be you know taught me new things
about my craft and and that's that's
kind of hard to find when you've been
doing it for as long as I have you would
think that not having any dialogue that
you would have to internalize and
memorize would make it easier but it's
actually the opposite right like you
have to be super aware of all of your
like sort of micro expressions and
everything because you can't fall back
or rely upon words to convey anything ex
but it's also you know I I realize that
you know sometimes you use your voice to
to sort of get away with maybe not
having quite the emotional charge that
you need for a scene you you know and
it's like and you kind of [__] your
way through it and you see the the you
see that expressed best than like
American TV you know like shitty TV yeah
I call it American whisper acting where
it's like how could you do this to me
man you know how could you and it's it's
sort of like What actors do and you know
I've been guilty of that as well where
you sort of you put an effect in your
voice to make it sound more emotional
but you don't really have the emotional
charge there and when you tell the story
with no dialogue and you have to do that
but it's just your eyes and your face it
just becomes flat if you don't have that
so I I I realize that the sort of the
process of
you know spinning up my emotion and and
the inner dialogue and the the pace of
my thoughts uh had to be much much more
higher and Intense or it had to be sort
of pure uh for the the expression in the
face and the eyes to to come out and
tell the story because I I didn't have
that crutch of a did you did you
recognize that in the process of doing
it or did you have that awareness like
going in that you were going to have to
deliver on that level in order to convey
some level of authenticity no it was
like day one when I was like oh [__]
like I really got to work here yeah I'm
not get I'm not going to get away with
anything but you went into it with a
with a sort of plan to go full method on
the whole thing right and not talk at
all and that kind of fell apart yeah you
know it it did fall apart pretty quickly
I um yeah it was it was sort of a Funny
Story with with me and my my fiance I
was like prepping her I I told the story
F and I was like I was I was prepping
her you know like I'm I think I'm going
to go like full method on this it's an
opportunity to to really like go in deep
and um you know cuz I've been I I play I
play around with that kind of
concentration not not like the idea of
method where you're were in character
the whole time and you sort of force the
whole crew to call you like Mr President
like I I've never done that but to sort
of stay in the concentration of the
character for the duration of the shoot
um and it's it's it's more to just kind
of spend time in the you know the
physicality and the voice of the
character you get more practice of it
and I I have done that sort of for for
for some projects and it has its pros
and its cons um so I was like this I
think this one I'm going to go like even
deeper I'm just going to be you know
silent for the whole shoot to just like
really harness that energy and and I was
like and that means that you know I'm
going to do it for the whole shoot you
know so I'm not going to be able to talk
to you we're not going to talk on the
phone and she's like what what the [__]
are you talking
about you're not going to talk to me you
mean you're not going to call me for two
months I'm like yeah I am an artist this
is what I do and then we had our talk
with my uh with our uh a relationship uh
coach Mark everyone needs a Mark um and
so I I had her all prepped up and she
was like okay like I you know I want to
be there for you and and for your
process and you know this is going to be
really tough for our relationship but
let's do this and then and
then like I didn't even last like I
landed in Mexico City and like called
her before I went through
immigration this will start when I get
to set yeah yeah exactly and then and
then yeah whatever yeah so but it's it
it's also like the the the real of the
story is I
also very early realized that if I step
back
and and have like sort of a singular
process where I'm only focused on my
performance uh I was I I was quickly
convinced that the movie would suffer
from that because like especially when
you have a role that where The Narrative
of the film is the character Arc you're
so in integral in the whole storytelling
apparatus and there's so much that you
can add and and also um um you know film
is a collaborative process and and if
you have a singular process like that
you're going to cut out all the other
artists that are on Set uh all the other
artists that are behind the the scenes
that are also there and ready to sort of
contribute with their art to make this
Collective art piece and and then you
just make it about yourself and um so
it's it's a it's it's a it's a loss in
that sense you know you lose a lot and
and I realize that like no I need to
really be
a leader on on this set well you're a
producer on the movie also right yeah
that that's not so important for this um
but but but yeah but but it's also you
know that John is sort of he's like a
quiet reserved you know like he he's
speaks with a very low voice and um so
then there becomes other you know voices
that are strong it can be like the first
uh the first assistant director that
sort of runs the show and and overall
the tone of the set can shift and and
become something else and that tone can
seep into the film as well so for me to
like kind of step out of it then I I
can't add my for me it's really
important like to to create a good vibe
on set and and to to have as many people
sort of feeling creative as possible
well when you're the lead you set the
tone for everybody right and if you're
brooding in the corner and not talking
to anyone like what does that do to the
like you know the espr core of everybody
else and then also if you want to get
feedback from woo on your performance
you're going to have to talk to the guy
I know it was the dumbest idea to be
quiet I don't know why
like so I'm glad I came to my senses
really quick it would have been an
absolute disaster um there's a lot of
like sort of shared DNA with this movie
with like you know the wick series
there's and there look there's no
there's no Wick without woo like John
Woo you know sets the stage and the
template for everything that we love
about John Wick um but in that kind of
shared
sensibility these fight sequences are
are like really grounded in reality you
know like they're not you're not a
superhero you know like you're actually
fighting the choreography feels
realistic it doesn't feel it you know
maybe it's heightened a little bit but
it doesn't feel like it's not something
that wouldn't actually happen because
you're not intended to be you know any
kind of superhuman person you're just an
average dude doing it um but the
training had to be intense I mean you
get this great montage and you get you
know like the whole the whole the whole
Rocky thing and like you know super guy
but like what was that like getting
ready to like you know be able to show
up with your shirt off like that yeah no
the the the key is you take all the
steroids and then and then you do three
push-ups every morning you know but
really strong videos is Joel Natty or
not like you know every time there's
some guy there videos like what's what's
the protocol yeah what's the reality of
like the Hollywood trainer culture yeah
I mean um you definitely uh uh you know
vitamin T and then uh okay you heard it
here um no I mean i' sort of figured out
how I how I like to train
and when you've done it a couple of
times it's sort of it's kind
of becomes kind of silly the whole sort
of shirtless scene you
know I feel silly you know putting so
yeah exactly um but you know for this it
was an important um you know it's
important to show that you the
transformation because he is the sort of
but in reality you know nobody would
look like that you know from training in
your garage you know that CU that's
mostly diet and you know vitamin T
um but yeah it's
um you know when you've done it a few
times I know how to just you know kind
of train and eat um you look like that
for like 24 hours exact you can't exact
that that's what it is um and um but
then when it comes to all the stunt
training and and that work you know it
that's sort of an accumulation of skills
I guess because I've done a few action
movies over the course of the years and
and I ended up working with the same
people a lot um so you know because
we've been working for several years uh
for this one and and and this was sort
of when my producer side sort of came
into it I was able to you know bring
this whole sort of stunt team into this
and the the the fight team at least and
um and because you know the the guy that
I was playing wasn't any kind of
Specialist or martial artist or you
didn't have any skills the way that we
wanted to make it exciting was was to to
make the F the fights like really
frenetic and uh and messy and U so me
and Jeremy Jeremy marinas who was the
fight coordinator on this who's also
fight coordinator on on the wick movies
and he's going to you know be a great
action director in his own right um we
we had this idea that we were going to
we were going to create the fights and
we really didn't wanted to look
choreographed um and um and the way that
we wanted to get away away from that was
to sort of to to to create these sort of
anchor points of of of choreography
where you know like a couple of moves
you know that this get slammed up
against the wall but then you know then
he gets loose and and gets all the way
over there and then the way that we get
there is sort of improvised and and it
is frenetic and um and the hard thing
that can be W with doing that is that
most Sun performers they're trained to
be very careful with the actor and
that's where it can look a little soft
and uh so I like Brazilian jiu-jitsu is
one of my like passions in life uh so I
would train a lot with the with the guys
I was uh you know working with and we
would do some some light Muay Thai
sparring as well so we became really
comfortable with you know training with
each other so when it came to the more
improvised parts of the fights we were
sort of comfortable with enough with
each other to sort of turn up the
intensity in those moments and you know
and you have you have these scenes where
I was working with this guy Vinnie we
did this fight sequence with in the in
the script it's like the suited man it's
the guy that I take captor in take
captive in the beginning and we we have
a we had a we had a really cool fight
scene in there but but you know it was
one scene where he was like you know
like pushing my face up and and I and I
looked at the the monitor I was like
Vinnie look like your your your your
your your fingertips are are not like
they're they're sparing my face you know
you can see it like you got to like you
got to dig so it was a lot of me sort of
pushing the stunk guys to like not go
easy on me um yeah so but if you're
grappling with them then they know where
that edge is how far they can push you
unconscious on
occasion um and then on top of that
there's all the driving stuff like so
you're doing it it looks like it's you
in the car doing all that and not all of
it I had all the all the the drifting
and all that kind of stuff yeah I I I I
was uh they taught me how to drift um
and so I can do some [__] but uh but
then I had you know Jeff who was my my
driving double who's like a wizard on
the wheel he was doing uh you know some
of the wider shots and and uh um yes so
there's a combination you know there
there's there's a level uh to what what
I can do but what I was doing quite a
bit like I I I I have some funny videos
where where you know cuz we we were
practicing for for a long time and uh so
uh yeah we put johnon in the car once
while we were rehearsing and uh we
thought it would be funny and and I
drove John around and uh just spinning
out with him so yeah I did I started
drifting a little bit and he was like
okay good go back
and he was like that's wild not
fun you don't like that at all um on the
dayto day like Jiu-Jitsu is your jam
like what's the what's the like wellness
fitness routine just on a normal day
when you're not prepping for a movie
what does that look like well for me it
it depends you know there's sort of one
routine that I have when it's just me
living life um and then it's one routine
when I'm sort of gearing up for
something and usually it depends on how
I want the character to look like um uh
you know for
example when I was sort of preparing for
Sympathy for the Devil with with Nick
Cage and then and then right after that
I I Was preparing for the fourth season
of For All
Mankind I was
uh for for four season of For All
Mankind I'm playing 72 years old uhhuh
so I had this idea that I need to lose a
lot of weight um so so my goal was to
lose 35 lbs um it's just the the sort of
the neck and the shoulders you know just
that's what kind of goes on on older men
yeah and um and I was going to wear this
sort of like you know fake belly on that
one but I just did I wanted to get the
the top part of my you know from my sort
of ribs and up to just look
skinnier um so I wanted to lose weight
for that and then and then the character
uh in in Sympathy for the Devil I was
you know Nick was sort of holding me
hostage there and uh the skinnier
smaller I got I I think the better it
was for the
dynamic um you know if you felt like
that we were at least sort of similar
size it was because I'm think I'm a
little bit bigger than Nick so you know
the the smaller I got the better it
would be for the dynamic of the film so
there I was on a mission to like lose
weight um but I'm trying to do it but
still be able to train uh just for my
mental health yeah and uh so so then
I'll just be training Jiu-Jitsu uh
because nothing makes me lose weight
more than if I just train jit if I just
train Jiu-Jitsu and do nothing else then
I lose weight um uh so if if I want to
maintain weight or or then I got to lift
weights and train we are not doing any
crazy fasting yeah no I was yeah yeah I
was did you you so you were able to lose
that much weight 35 lbs yeah I was uh I
was fasting 18 to 20 hours wow yeah for
almost eight months it yeah it was and
then you go into For All Mankind and
you're sitting in the makeup chair for
hours making you look like an old man
yeah day and then and then I felt like
it didn't do as much as I wanted it to
do um so all that effort yeah it was
like I saw it did give a difference but
um but yeah it was yeah I was down to
166 and I'm usually like 195 wow and
you're like 63 right yeah yeah yeah
that's pretty I'm usually like between
uh between 195 and 200 that's where
I um I haven't seen the niage movie yet
I saw the trailer for it and for some
reason it escaped me like I'm like when
did this come out did it come out this
summer yeah it was uh it was one of
those unfortunate things that happened
with the strike so they' set a Rel
release date and we were supposed to do
press we had the Press day
set and then and then the strike got
announced and uh we were we there was an
opportunity to do the Press right before
the the strike kicked in like literally
like two hours before the strike kicked
in and then Nick felt that it was not
being good solidar you know not showing
solidarity to
it I was uh very open to doing the
interviews cuz I I mean the strike
hadn't started yet we had two hours like
I'm very pragmatic with those kind of
things um but um yeah so so we we we we
didn't we didn't know press for it yeah
I heard nothing about it and then uh and
it kind of just got released into the
void I'm going to watch it now though
cuz it looks it looks pretty wild it's
co like it's a tiny movie uh but it's
basically me and cage in a car you know
I had I had to got to experience a lot
of cage rage you know directly at my
face I can't decide whether that guy is
a lunatic or a genius or both but
there's a pretty strong argument that
he's the greatest living movie star that
we have I mean that guy is like unique
in every way like what is he like what
is that like working with him in person
uh it's like justce advertised you know
like the first day that we rehearse you
know I I we go to his house me and yal
the director and knock on his door this
is house in Vegas and he opens up is
that where he lives he lives in Vegas in
Vegas yeah and he opens the door he's
like h
and I'm like hey and he's got pink hair
and then he's like [__] I'm like what
he's like my cat my cat ran away it's my
wild cat it's the third time he does it
and I'm like oh okay and he's like come
in and then and then we walk in and and
his house is like a uh it's a little
Gothic and and in the living room he's
got his big bird cage and and he's like
here's hogy hogy hogy and he starts
yelling at his bird bir I'm like [__]
this is so good he's like that's miles
he's my reptile manager I'm like okay
what's up miles and then we go down in
the basement and then we start
rehearsing and on the first day of
rehearsal uh he's completely off book on
the entire script he's on his feet uh
rehearsing like full Patty and uh you
know it's it's we're like 10 days away
from shooting a movie and he's he has
the whole script memorized and just
really has a has a very clear idea of
what he's doing with this character and
it's like a wild you know it's a it's a
wild take on the character and um and
it's uh I got to I got to give him an
award and when I was in Saudi they they
gave him some sort of appreciation award
and uh and I had this sort of speech
written that I handed in to the
producers where I was talking about his
acting balls but uh apparently they they
didn't want that on Saudi TV so I had to
cut it had to cut that line but I was
like I was talking we talk about acting
balls and and Nick's acting balls are
like [__] watermelons cuz it's
like you know he never plays it safe you
know he and and and he goes for it every
time and it doesn't matter what movie it
is he's like balls to the wall yeah 100%
And it's
uh like the kind of like he always has
such uh
fascinating like he his his choices are
all always so extreme you know and it
and it you know it's risky it means you
can miss of course you know there's a
bigger likelihood that you can't miss
but also that's when you that's how you
create the most memorable characters
that have ever been made and and you
know where it's pure genius and I like I
that's not my Approach I
I'm I try to find a
more you know subtle way to to tell I
try tried to sort of Mel the character
with some something of my own you know I
create a new body language and way of
talking and stuff like that but um but
it's a sort of a more subtle way I I
Tred to you know find the the most
subtle way to tell the story and he's
not interested in naturalism and and he
says that so I was I was so fascinated
to work with him I was actually chasing
a project to to do with him because I I
really wanted the experience to to see
how he works and like just as advertised
and uh yeah but he has his own internal
Logic for all for all of those choices
like when press are asked he can tell
you exactly why he's doing what he's
doing as Extreme as it may be um but I'm
just envisioning you like you know in
the car with him or whatever take and
he's throwing something insane at you
and you've got to figure out how to you
know react yeah in real in real time to
some unexpected thing did so many crazy
things he did so many crazy things while
we were shooting that movie it
was he had these like improvisations
that was like
officer now I have to watch it is it
streaming where can you see this yeah I
think I think it's on Hulu I think it
might be on Hulu he is the best uh I
love Nick so much and and I'm so happy
that like he exists and and that I mean
I was pinching myself many times but he
he made it impossible to to to act
sometimes you know cuz he would just go
into these like really absurd
improvisations of him like you know yeah
it's he was like jerking off his like
massive uh imaginary dick while the
police had just pulled him off he was
like
officer officer he was like doing this
oh my God this this is impossible to
have in a movie and and I think he was a
lot of the things he was doing kind of
to entertain himself as well but yeah
he's uh he's a genius
yeah every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra great on the trails and I just got
the new NextGen Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm loving those but an also has
this incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly anchors your phone
no jiggle I'm just so proud to partner
with an and I love their vision for the
future where their gear is fossil free
and engineered for circularity so check
out their amazing lineup of super
comfortable sleek and durable pieces for
yourself at
on.com speaking of you know making more
nuanced choices or kind of being
intentional about how you inhabit a role
I mean I think like most people in
America my introduction to you was in
The Killing um that was your first truly
American kind of introduction no that
was my first job in the US it wasn't it
it was yeah that's what I thought right
that's what brought you here from Sweden
no I had already come here I I came here
to sort of to try it out and then I was
uh uh you know doing auditions and so
you you were already living here when
you got that yeah yeah yeah well you had
done that um what was the other movie
that you did that kind of came out right
around the same time the Weinstein
Company movie where you want it was a
Swedish movie you got like a actor uh
yeah it snaba cash easy money yeah yeah
but that was a Swedish movie yeah yeah
no so I had a I was working in Sweden
and and then and then I moved to the
states right and uh and then I was doing
auditions and you did a a shitload of
stuff in Sweden before you before the
killing I mean your IMDb is like 10
miles long of all the Swedish stuff that
you did before you came here I had a
intense
um intense uh career in Sweden
um I finished acting school in 2007 and
and I was on stage for a couple of years
in the on National Theater and then at
the same time I did uh I did nine
features in 16 months wow um I played
the lead in in six of them so so it was
like a very intense and then and then I
moved to to the states MH and the
killing was sort of the first it sort of
the introduction to an American audience
of like this scandy Noir like genre that
now we can all enjoy on Netflix like I
just I love watching all the you know
all these like crime noirs that are all
all from that part of the world um so
dark and you know not interested in
Happy Endings and not at all yeah and
and the killing you know was definitely
that but your character was almost uh on
some level like comedic relief like the
choices that you were making about that
guy it was it it was really riveting
like you made an indelible impression
you're like who is that dude you know
and then now here you are like the
hardest working man in Hollywood like
you're all over the place but that must
have been the reception to that must
have been pretty cool at the time
because that show was a big deal when it
aired yeah but it was a it was a weird
show because it was um you know it's
such a long time ago now um and the sort
of TV space was so different than it was
like right in the beginning beginning
still of the sort of golden era of TV
where audiences were audiences were
still sort of steeped in an
older uh older tradition and had
expectations that were different because
like the the first season the the the
the season finale of the first season of
of that show uh created an
outrage and people were Furious I don't
remember that and abandoned the show
because it was a whole season where you
know you're going to they were sort of
they felt that they were promised that
they were going to find out who the
killer was in the end of the first
season and then they didn't you didn't
find out on that and um and people were
Furious and and and like abandoned the
show and it was like uh and and then the
second season uh was you know in the
first season we were sort of like marray
got nominated and it there was sort of
like good and then the second season it
was like just abandoned by critics and
um
and and then it and then it got
cancelled after two seasons um and then
and then the third season got picked up
again and it was actually Netflix second
show that they produced it was a
co-production with Netflix they' only
done house of cards right and then they
co-produced the third season of uh uh of
the killing together with AMC and then
it got cancelled again AMC canceled it
and then Netflix ended up picking up
like an abbreviated uh fourth season of
it so it was a show that sort of really
found an intense audience um but it was
cancelled twice and then and then sort
of after the fact on streaming it
really um it it it you know I I still
like people that sort of know me from
that show they always they're always
friendlier to me than than people that
know me from other things there's
something with that character because
because well there was something very
endearing about him as [__] up as he
was you know like you you were he was he
seemed like a good hang even though he
was like chaotic and unstable and like
you know in his owned up way yeah I love
playing holder and that was sort of an
interesting transition because that's a
remake of a Swedish show Danish show
Danish show oh was Danish yeah we used
to We own them for a while so it's okay
but uh yeah okay um but I assume that
that then led to you know all of these
opportunities like getting noticed in
that um opened up the door for you yeah
yeah I mean I was uh pretty arrogant and
uh full of myself there for a while yeah
and uh yeah I uh cuz I there was a while
when I was like just like just [__]
cancel the show already I want to go
make big movies and uh be a movie star I
don't have time for this [__] anymore
and then and then and then but I was
glad that I at least while I was
shooting the show I I kind of when it
came back I I I did really app
appreciate um that it it was something
special and and also like me and
marray uh we got along so well and I
mean we're we're close friends to this
day and um and then what what was really
special with that show too
was I mean we had so many great
directors there's so many like feature
film directors that came in and did
episodes but Jonathan
Demi um the the the you know the Silence
of the Lamb and
the legend he he fell in love with the
show and then you know called Vina and
asked if he could come direct and then
he directed uh an episode in in the
third season and then he ended up uh
directing the series finale oh wow and
uh yeah and he was just a he was one of
those sort of um a bright genius like he
was he was he had he he was like a
friendly friendly genius you know he
every he was like a son you know that
like when when he looked at people they
just kind of like warmed up and and like
blossomed you know he he just had
this he engaged everyone everyone just
uh he's a beautiful man yeah yeah he
died way too soon Legend obviously when
you're early in your career you're
auditioning you just want to get jobs or
whatever but now in the position that
you're in now what is the process like
how do you how do you choose what to get
involved with like what are the
variables or the parameters that are
most important to you when you're
looking at a project to decide like is
this something I want to be in or invest
in yeah I mean uh the the most important
thing I mean the two most important
things are the the director and the
character um I think before I would
actually put the director further down
and I would put the character first um
now though they're sort of equal and I
and I realize that I I think it's also
it's a different um it's a different
thinking when you're coming up and uh
and when you're trying to make an make a
name for yourself than when you're sort
of at a level and you want to make great
things cuz like coming up it can even be
good to to you know have a great role in
a sort of semi shitty project because
you you have a chance to shine you know
um and you can like if you're great and
everyone else is mediocre or or then um
you know you'll get noticed so I think
that's sort of how I looked at things
when I was coming up I I was like like
if I if I saw a role like I know I can
make something out of that and and it
doesn't matter who the director is like
as long as they stay out of my way um
but then but then now it's
like it doesn't matter if you're going
to do a great performance in something
that is a piece of [__] right because
nobody's going to see it and uh so uh so
now for me it's uh it's like
director character story um I mean
they're all really and and it it kind of
has to check all the
boxes
um and then I think you know money is
number four yeah of course I mean but
the thing is like you're in an industry
where there isn't a ton of agency over
what you get to do but now that you're
like this leading man and you're in all
these movies and you've established that
you can you know do the thing and um
you're bankable in that regard when you
look at the careers of of So many actors
you know maybe great and not so great
their legacy or how we perceive them or
how we think of them as artists and what
their careers mean boils down to the
choices that they made and some are
really good at choosing the right
projects and then they have this
extraordinary Legacy and this this like
catalog of amazing work and others who
who are perhaps equally as talented or
as bankable for some reason their picker
isn't as good or who knows what's going
on or maybe it's this luck and you know
look nobody goes into a movie um
thinking you know trying to make a bad
movie like it's almost a miracle when
when a movie gets made let alone is good
um but at this and and there's only so
much control you have over that but you
see these people and you're like oh if
they just done this or this or they
hadn't done that or whatever and then
suddenly they're out of the game and
their career is on a very different Arc
or trajectory so those choices that you
make become like really Mission critical
in terms of of how you think about your
career and the longevity of what you
want to do and what you want to stand
for as an artist yeah no you you you
nailed it it's
um yeah especially it's exactly that
when you get to that position
where you uh have built up an audience
and and people are sort of you know you
want to create a feeling that oh we can
go see you know a Joel kinman movie and
uh and and it's going to have a certain
amount of quality like it might not
might not always be uh like a hit but
there's going to be a certain level like
there's an a certain kind of taste that
that is um that that you know that you
can deliver on in some way and it comes
down to taste and how you pick but then
you know there's a lot of variables of
course so you can't control it all and
uh and at my level I I I can't control
it all but but uh yeah it's uh and you
know you also I work with people as well
and and I get their input and you know
of course the decision comes down it's I
make the decision of course but I'm very
happy with like my manager and my agents
and um so you know we discuss these
things and and you you try to uh you
know limit the the the probability of of
it not being good you know yeah um but
then for me it's also really important
that the character scares me a little
bit you know it's a because I'm also all
always focusing on avoiding stagnation
you know both as a person and as an
artist and uh so it you know that that's
why I really tried to stay away from you
know playing the same kind of character
over and over again and and it's sort of
the the artistic tradition that I come
from in Europe where the highest is
always to as an actor to you know do the
most different kind of characters you
know that's what Nick Cage is like the
the the most incredible expression of
that um but um but but that is that is
sort of in me the whole time I'm trying
to stay like you know 10% outside of my
comfort zone and everything that I do
who's the director that you most want to
work with who were the who are who's
like at the top of the list of the
people like if you had your
brothers
um you know of course Tarantino you know
it's
um
he's you know been behind so many iconic
uh characters say the safty brothers
yeah um are they are they still going to
be directing together I think they're
kind of doing their own separate things
right now okay so probably they're
exciting filmmakers though
really really
exciting um and you see the kind of
performance that they get from their
actors and they choose you know act you
know they get what's what's so
fascinating with them and and you see
that they they IM help the actor immerse
thems into the world that they are
portraying so you know they get someone
like Rob Patterson or oh yeah what they
got out of him in good time is insane
that movie is unreal yeah I mean Rob is
you know
becoming one of the the you know he's
one of the greatest of of Our Generation
for sure you know and and he makes
really interesting choices that are
counterintuitive I I've I've always like
really commended him you know cuz he got
super famous with and was like really
you know hounded Paparazzi famous after
the the whole his vampire movies and
because he also got you know mixed into
you know tabloid City with with with the
the girlfriend that he had at the
time so he would he he had that like
really high level of Fame so you know
the the studios were throwing every
spandex suit they could find on him and
he just would not put them on you know
he he he didn't do any you know
superhero stuff or any any anything that
would you know that other actors would
like kind of jump on because you know
it's a it's this kind of a straight
ticket to A-list level where you can
really be bankable for for bigger
projects and um and he just he instead
went off and did a bunch of strange
movies with really interesting directors
so he basically went to film school yeah
and you know Cronenberg and you know all
all these films that he did and he he
went to film school and and and started
working with really interesting artist
and then became a very interesting
artist himself so you know then put on
the Batman suit and then comes back and
does Batman I mean that's like that's
how you do it he won like Rob one I it's
pretty funny uh speaking of great
directors I watched
um Girl with the Dragon tatto like two
weeks ago I was like revisiting all
these fer movies getting ready to watch
the Killer and hilariously like you're
you're like a staffer at Millennium
magazine in that movie like in the
background you have like no lines I know
do you have a single line in that movie
uh I think I whisper something was that
before the
killing no it was during so did you have
did you get edited out did you have
lines that got edited out of that or
whatever no no no I was I was cast for
the second and third movie um so that
character became a bigger character in
the second and third movies um but then
they never ended up happening and then
and then Fincher decided that he wanted
to introduce the character in that in
those scenes just you know just wanted
to place him there you're just kind of
around I know it's pretty
funny coming from Sweden and living here
uh what are the kind of cultural
differences between the Swedish
perspective on I don't know life and
lifestyle versus United States like one
of the things like we open this with
talking about Wim Hoff a little bit like
it's all about cold plunging and sauna
here and it's like well this goes back
thousands of years and sweet it must be
hilarious to you that everyone's like
losing their minds over this yeah I mean
it's great you know it it's also now
when there's so much literature around
it and and people understand how how
good it is for your health you know and
I in both in Sweden and Finland you
know the Swedish and finish uh
traditions of also drinking vodka in the
sauna you know I don't know if that is a
real like longevity measure um but um
yeah I mean I think we have a more sort
of stoic um approach to life and and I
think uh you know it's really like East
and West thing where
um where I think Sweden is also you know
pretty far east and and when when
someone asks you you know like how you
doing and uh then you know it's a very
reasonable thing to say like bad you
know not good today you know just heavy
you know I just feel like I have a heavy
day you know just woke up feeling really
Melancholy and then that's that okay and
then and that can be a conversation
where so that was like an issue for me
when I moved here and I was sort of um
going to the meetings with Hollywood
producers and casting agents and in you
know like bright California and and and
you know you you sit down in these
meetings and to get to know each other
and sort of you're intended to like show
your personality and my my approach to
that was like I'm G to like be who I am
you know that's that's that's the
personality they have so that's the only
one I'm going to show
and um so when I woke up feeling
Melancholy on a day and I would go into
one of these meetings with you know
these like bright faed uh casting agents
and they were like Hi H how how you
feeling today how how you doing and I
would be like it's it's okay you know I
just and I you know I just feel pretty
heavy today I just felt like you know
you know I don't know what I'm doing
here you know what what's what what is
this all about and I just be
quiet and you just see that their faces
just fell you know and and I'm like you
know it's okay I'm fine you I'm not
going to kill myself but I'm just you
know just heavy today how you doing and
then and and then I learned later like
you know I get the feedback like is is
he okay and and my my manager would be
like you know you might want to like
brighten it up a little bit and uh so I
I learned I learned that the the hard
way that when they ask you know how you
doing it's not it's not a real question
there's a is there a bit is this true or
false like there's a bit of a tall poppy
syndrome thing in in Sweden right like
oh yeah yeah yeah we call it the the law
of yant the yant law y yeah I don't know
what it's why it's called that it's just
the name so how does that work with you
saying I'm going to go to America and be
a movie star with your buddies back home
yeah um yeah so I think my personality
is probably like pretty UNS Swedish um
and uh and I think I
my I I really looked up to the sort of
American Spirit and U of uh you know and
I and I loved how people here kind of
celebrate others other people's success
you know it it's a um it's much less of
that sort of like jealous snipin of like
cutting someone down that's trying
something different and so I I sort of a
acknowledged and saw that existing here
and and I love that I thought that this
so much more positive I for me the whole
thing of like feeling shitty or being
disappointed in someone else's success
was always like such a sign of weakness
to me it it was like I I don't
understand like I don't I'm not
like my house isn't getting you know
smaller cuz his house is getting bigger
you know it's a uh so to not be inspired
by other people's success and and
feeling like shitty and and then talking
[__] about it it like such a uh I
thought it was such a sign of weakness
and and uh and sort of that you didn't
have the the Insight that you were kind
of embarrassing yourself what and
behaving that way um so I think I had
that analysis down pretty quickly in in
in Sweden and and I and I remember
like in my group of friends uh it was it
was a lot of competition and uh and and
I I had a whole group of friends where I
felt that you know they weren't on my
team you know they weren't celebrating
My Success um and and I I was
celebrating their theirs and uh and I
wasn't threatened by them doing well um
but uh but it wasn't the other way
around so it it came to a point where I
actually had a like I broke up with a
whole um my whole like older group of
friends in Sweden and and just like
focused on like three or four of those
friends you had done a lot of work in
Sweden as a young person I'm sure you
know in that country people knew who you
were um and then at some point you like
took a break right and just traveled
like I don't know if you quit acting but
you were like I'm done for a while and
you went and did a whole bunch of
different things and had weird jobs and
stuff like that was that like an
intentional way of like just getting
perspective on on what you wanted to do
and who who you wanted to be or what was
that all about that that was actually
before I I started acting oh it was yeah
so so it was I finished uh you know high
school or or the equivalent in Sweden
and uh and then I went to to Norway and
uh just had a bunch of odd jobs to save
money to go travel and and I I hadn't
made up my mind of what I wanted to do
so I had this idea that I was going to I
was going to work and travel for seven
years before I made up my mind of what I
want to do with my
life seven years seven years why seven
be like I'll take a year or something
yeah no I don't know it was uh that that
that's just something I had in my mind
like my my whole family is sort of
Travelers
um uh everyone's like been sort of a
Backpacker my my dad is is a crazy story
but um but even my mom and all my
sisters we've all been you know going
traveling around the world and and
that's been a you know big part of our
family
culture um so so it was just something I
wanted to see the world and and I I had
no idea what what I wanted to do with my
life and uh wasn't very confident in
anything I wasn't particularly good in
anything I didn't have any sort of
academic uh Prospect like because I I I
I kind of [__] up school so so it it
was just uh I just want I was just going
to make money uh I was pretty good at
like hustling making money and uh and
then I was going to go travel that was
sort of my idea and how did the acting
thing come about then so I'd actually
done a TV series when I was 10 years old
so I had like a childhood acting
experience and my oldest sister she was
an actor so she sort of introduced that
it was a profession and um and then I
got this opportunity to do this like TV
series in Sweden so I had i' had a
childhood experience of it when I was 10
and then sort of forgot about that and
and then some of my friends uh were
actors they were like they were going to
acting school there was a couple of them
so I was I had this I had this like
childhood experience of it and and then
you know I had these friends that were
doing it and then after like a year and
a half of traveling I just had this idea
like you know maybe I'll try that you
know maybe I'll try that and then I
started working with my friend uh gusta
scar guard who's uh uh Alex scarg
guard's younger brother and Stella scar
son as well um and I started working
with
him and uh and he was kind of shaking
his head but uh but I I didn't give up
and and he gave me enough uh confidence
to kind of continue and then I decided
that I was going to uh try out for the
National Theater school and uh and I
worked with this
actor with an older actor I got a hold
of an older actor that agreed to like
work with me and and I was working on
this uh this monologue from Long Day's
Journey Into Night by Eugene O'Neal and
it was this
text where like Edmund just finally like
goes against his dad and just lets him
hear every every like you know all of
his he lets out all of his frustration
and anger and sad sadness at his dad's
you know failures and and him not being
there not caring and uh and I'd had my
own issues with my
dad and uh and it was like the and it
would in one of the
rehearsals when I was was working with
this text and then something just
clicked in and the text just like kind
of came alive and it just took over and
I got like filled with emotion and the
words just came flying out in a in a way
that I wasn't really planning them and
um and I understood later like this was
the first time I gotten flow um and
uh and you know after the scene was done
I was kind of like panting and just
quiet and and and and you know of course
I understood in some way that like this
is probably not bad and um and then that
actor Thomas he was like okay listen you
can you can do this as a profession um
but you it's going to be a lot of work
but but you you you can do this as a
profession you got locked in yeah yeah
that's got to be an intoxicating feeling
though to know that you can connect with
the material in that way and channel
something from a flow State based on
your experience and some facility for
inhabiting a character yeah that was a
high you know it was a real natural high
and uh yeah and then I got really
addicted to that feeling and I was
chasing that and um and then I just
became obsessed and
and it was also I hadn't really
experienced being good at anything
before like I've been okay you know I
was okay at
sports um but I was never like great at
anything um so it was the first time
where I like there was something that
just kind of caught me in and I felt
like I could maybe be good at something
and and that just changed my
whole outlook and view on the
possibility of my life and um yeah I
like started looking at myself with a
different like level of potential and
respect in a way and uh and then I just
and then that feeling just it just
started like vibrating and then and it
just made me be become completely
obsessed and I did nothing but it uh but
but focusing on acting and and trying to
get as good as possible and that's super
interesting I you know did have like a
peak experience like that but also to
have the self-awareness the presence of
mind to like recognize that that was a
special moment and could perhaps lead
your entire life in a different
direction yeah and it makes me wonder
like you can't you can't have those
experiences unless you're putting
yourself out there and trying lots of
things so many people go through life
and maybe they never have an experience
like that because they keep their lives
sort of contained in a certain way
um but then of the people that are lucky
enough to you know trip upon their
version of that type of experience what
is the quality within an individual to
like help them lock onto that and
realize like the gravity of it or the
importance or like the potential it's
like potential energy right like oh
here's something if I nurture this maybe
I can have a different kind of Life yeah
yeah I mean I don't know uh I think it's
uh it's GNA it's going to it has to be
so individual right it's like it has to
sort of collide with your history and
your life and and then the more I
started working and then you know deeper
in I I started seeing that sort of my
life experience and and the different
experiences that I've had and and in
many ways like all the the problems that
I'd had and
uh and all the trauma all the trauma
that I had experienced in my life all of
a sudden weren't like something that was
dragging me down but it was actually
like my greatest assets yeah it was it's
like fertile soil yeah and and I was
like [__] I I have all these pieces and
all these experiences that I can like
put into characters that I don't think
that most people can and so
it um yeah and then you used to have a
bunch of SARS guards around you
yeah cuz everybody in Sweden knows
everyone right yeah yeah and there's one
high school the crazy thing
is me um gusta Scar Guard I think Bill
scar scard too numi rapas who plays a
girl with
tattoo uh we all went to the same high
school what and Alexander also I Alex
lived right right next door to that that
high school because that's where the
scars guards lived but uh but I think he
went to another school actually that's a
pretty high hit rate you know like per
capita yeah crazy there needs to be like
a plaque or something like that have you
gone back to to your high school or or
like Revisited you know that that you
know place to kind of marinate and no I
actually didn't really fully
graduate they'll give you an honorary
degree though you can go back there at
some point they they it's called like uh
in Swedish called Sam document it's like
a it's like a a collection of your
grades but it's not like a diploma
because I actually didn't get enough
points
[Music]
to you have a place in Sweden now right
yeah we have sort of a family place um
so a few years ago I bought a plot of
land in archipelago and um and we've
just been adding little houses so I
built like a family Village uhhuh which
island uh it's in the archipelago it's
it's called vda um it's like an hour and
a half from Stockholm I've Traverse the
archipelago oh really I mean there's
40,000 islands in the stockam
archipelago so I did the uh I'm going to
butcher this pronunciation so you tell
me how bad this
is do you know what that is
otillo the swimrun World Championships
okay which is the swim it's a 75
kilometer race where you you start in
santom and you go to uto it's like 75
kilm and you go you swim and run across
all the islands you're in like a
modified wet suit with your running
shoes on and so you're swimming with
your running shoes on and you climb up
the rocks and you run across these
islands and you jump back in the water
you basically go is that this s of Iron
Man
it's like own thing that started there
and now there's a series of these races
all over the world have you done Iron
Man are you in that sort of did yeah I
do a bunch of endurance stuff yeah yeah
yeah but I did I think it was
2017 that I did that race okay yeah so
it was pretty cool so I got to see up
close and personal what those islands
are like so beautiful what's the most uh
challenging thing that you've done that
was the hardest one day thing that I've
ever done how many hours does does it
take oh I think it was like 9 or 10
hours or something like that but the
guys that that are so first of all on
that day it was like the world's worst
weather there was like sideways rain we
got a lot of that four to six foot like
chop it was banana like all day it was
like the most miserable experience ever
and then you're freezing in the water
and then you're running across these
islands and you're in like a wet suit so
you start to get overheated and just
when you start to warm up then you're
back in the you're like uncomfortable
the entire time um so that yeah as a
one-day thing that was probably the
hardest but I've done I've done this
race called Ultram man it's a three-day
double Iron Man around the big island of
Y and I've done that a bunch of times
Jesus done well in that race and then I
did five Iron Man Iron Man wasn't enough
I never did just an iron man I went to
the longer
stuff it's a whole other thing but this
is not about me this is about you but my
point being yeah but I'm curious my
point being uh I I know those I know the
archipelago uh better than most and
what's interesting about that race is
when the gun goes off like I'm a good
swimmer so I was like near you know I
was in good position the you the First
Swim is like a kilometer Crossing and
then you get to this island on the other
side and I've been training around here
in the mountains and just desert and
whatever going to the pool and then
doing trail running and I thought that
would be good and and these like Swedish
Special Forces guys who train year round
on this course to win this race climb
out of the water and they're dancing on
these rocks like ballet dancers and I'm
we're everybody's falling and some guy
cracked his head open immediately you
know it's not like it's like an obstacle
course as much as anything else yeah it
was wild wow so me we ran across your
Island I don't know where your compound
there um but you know Midsummer like
that time of year in that part of the
world is just the greatest thing yeah
yeah it's pretty
epic we have uh like on our property we
have this uh we have a sauna that's it's
legally a boat so it's like on a raft it
was initially it was to to get away from
having to apply for building permits
it's hard to get building permits close
to the the coast um it's and all the all
the dwellings on all those islands look
like it it it definitely looks like it's
controlled like you can't just build
whatever you want yeah and it it's it's
very it's very much about how it Blends
into the nature and like we have all of
our houses when when you uh it's like
it's like six houses now on the property
but when you come from the ocean you
almost can't see them because they're
all like they're all colored like the
wood it's like wood colored and with
like blue so it kind of Blends into the
sky and that's very much a sort of
Swedish aesthetic to like you you you
you sort of RA nature is the highest and
and you want to leave as little of a
footprint as possible so that's also the
laws like you can't have too much glass
because that it creates glare and um wow
yeah um it's often said that the
Scandinavian countries have like the
highest happy quotient like people are
just happier there than they are in
other parts of the world despite the
fact that the winter is like endless and
it's you know dark most of the time like
when you reflect upon your upbringing
there your Swedish Heritage like what
why do you think that is what is the
what is is the sensibility of those
cultures that lead to a greater degree
of happiness than we experience here I
don't know I mean I don't know how much
you can actually like if if those are
true those like sort of how
people I I mean if you watch scandy Noir
it doesn't look like
everyone I I think that there you know
there is a general sense uh of you know
I think more people in general are sort
of in contact with nature and in nature
spend time in
nature um I think we have things like
you know we
SAA uh get in the ocean even when it's
colder um I think those things are are
probably very good um but I mean I know
a lot of depressed sweds too and I think
the suicide rate is pretty high as well
so um and and the level of like
alcoholism especially in the north is is
pretty high as well but um the Danes
seem to be happier than than the swedes
uh Finland yeah and the the fins are
definitely not happy I
mean they're definitely not happy um I
mean they're almost Russian you know
it's the fins are their own thing
they're uh
um I don't know I think
uh I think that there there is sort of a
some level of stoicism in in society
that um you sort of like accept the way
things are and and
uh I think
that's I think people don't have too
much expectation either you know I think
uh um I think sweds are pretty good at
managing their expectations so so they
won't get that disappointed there's also
a safety net everyone kind of knows they
can only fall so far before they'll be
caught and my sense is just that
everybody's out moving all the time
doesn't matter how dark or cold it is
like they're they're they're skating on
the Frozen Waters or they're cross
country skiing or they're swimming or
they're you know jumping in freezing
water and like in a way that isn't is
does feel different than here yeah no
for sure I and that's sort of what I was
was getting to with like people being in
nature people I think exercise much more
in general the level of obesity is uh uh
is very different than here and um they
feel like they're working to live more
than we we we we sort of live to work
here yeah it's uh the the general work
week is you know 40 hours uh so I think
that's probably a lot less than uh than
here and uh and then we have a lot the
normal Suite has six weeks vacation six
to eight weeks a year yeah so
so there there's there's definitely that
um when you look back on your career I
mean you came here to you
know plant your flag in Hollywood and
you've certainly done that right and
feels like didn't take that long I'm
sure maybe it feels like it was longer
than maybe you would have liked but on
some level like you've realized your
dreams and your Ambitions and I'm sure
there's plenty of more things that you
want to do and goals that you have and
all of that but when you upon that like
what do you think like certainly Talent
luck like a lot of things have to
coincide for this this type of success
but do you think that you have a certain
strength or quality that has allowed you
to
succeed like what is it what is your
what is your
superpower I think I you know I have a
grind in me um and
I like I I I I wouldn't take
uh failure as you know I wouldn't accept
failure and and I think when i' when
I've met when I've come across like
real real adversity I I found the
method in me I I used to have um I've
told the story before but it's it's one
of my most most important things that
happened to me and and sort of how what
I grew out of it I used to have really
really punishing stage fright where I
would throw up every time before I went
on
stage it's hard it's hard to believe
that yeah um and
um and then I would start
getting panic attacks uh on stage
and and it was just it it was just an
accumulation where and that was still in
acting school school when when this was
happening and it was like I was I had
these like voices in my head that were
you know it was of course it was like
insecurity and and and it it was
like I was faced with the with the
reality that like maybe I'm not equipped
to do this uh because it's clear like
I'm I'm I'm going up on stage and I'm
not being able to do it because I'm
because of what's Happening inside my
head wow and so so I was I was about
three years into acting school and I
just had this horrendous
breakdown in front of the whole school
and an audience with people from the
outside where I just so completely lost
it and I couldn't
recover um and and I was just felt
humiliated and um and
embarrassed and I had this like
long talk with myself where I was like I
I maybe this is me telling myself that
you know this is it so but then the idea
of to quit was you know it was like to
quit it was it felt like killing myself
um because I
hadn't you know Finding acting was the
it just gave me this whole purpose in
life it it it I I felt like my identity
before acting was just like a little
Thug that was you know just a hustler
kind of living a pretty ugly life where
you know I would do a lot of different
things to just get money and you
know I mean I was I I was like robbing
people and like like the character and
the killing a little bit little little
bit was you know and I really didn't
have any moral compass I
mean uh selling [__] and just just not
living a positive like it was it was
like I don't think that I would have
ended up being a career criminal at all
but but but it was just I was just
living a a negative life and with shitty
people around and then and then this
acting thing just really like opened up
something for me it was like a
possibility it was like a window into a
different life and feeling and I
understood later it it opened up a a a
window of like feeling differently about
myself
so when I was sort of confronted with
this it was so devastating and uh and
and it was and I couldn't accept it but
I didn't know what to do like I like I
didn't know what to do I didn't know
what to do
um so then I in in that in that Darkness
I sort of came up with
this like Hail Mary of an idea I was
like these [__] demons that are in my
head like these voices that like [__]
me that ruin everything like what is the
worst thing that they could experience
like what is the worst thing and then
and then I figured out it would be to do
like a monologue on stage where I'm like
just just me nothing and I and I
just uh and I was like okay I'm I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna do I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm going to challenge these and
and the next project that we had in
school was we had our own projects and
it was like a a 3- week deal where we
got to do our own thing for 3 weeks and
most people took it as sort of a break
they did like one scene together like
four people did one
scene and I found this play uh called ho
the rookie it was like this uh play from
Northern Ireland and it's it's written
for two people where the first person is
is then featured in the second uh
storytellers and I did both and and I
ended up doing this play I I ended up
creating 16 different characters
characters that all had like a different
body and a different voice and and I
started rehearsing this play like I was
obsessed like I was possessed and uh it
was like an hour it ended up being like
about an hour and 40 minutes long I knew
it by heart after 10 days like I was off
because it was all I did and um and then
and then we presented in for the school
and uh and I don't know there was
something I was like just overcome with
like I I was I was so obsessed with with
with kind of defeating this like I guess
it was fear or I don't know what it was
but not accepting myself as
a success or or you know I I don't know
what it what it was like what those
voices actually are that sort of
insecurity but played it and uh didn't
trip on a word like
just uh smashed it and ended up doing
five performances of
that and then it that play got picked up
by the National Theater so I actually
ended up continu to playing it
professionally and after that because
that's actually like really high
difficulty level um you know because I
had so many different characters and I
was sort of playing it in in the format
of like uh I watched I I wanted to sort
of make it Feel Like Richard
PRI you know stand up one man show kind
that sort of way of like talking you
know where um where the characters would
talk with each other and and uh um you
know and of course I didn't have the
pressure of needing to be funny um but
it had F funny elements in it but after
that then the first job that I got after
I finished acting
school
um was was to play RC nikov in crime and
punishment and uh and it it was also the
the opening play of a new National
Theater with with one of the best
Swedish maybe the best Swedish playright
that did a whole new re revamp and I was
on the stage for three hours and 40
minutes doing rosol nikov and I think
that would have been like really
crippling uh for me before this for sure
and but for anyone it was like a lot of
pressure for that to be your first job
but after have done
this this monologue it felt like nothing
like I had so much it felt like so much
easier and and that's sort of that was
the the inflection point in my career
that's where everything changed and I
and I found a way to like create real
confidence by facing my fears and uh and
like and going going at at headon and um
and it it that I found that solution in
that Darkness it changed everything for
me and it also became sort of a metric
of how I've dealt
with difficult times ahead to run
towards them yeah to face it and and to
uh and to like challenge it and it's
like
okay let's F go right yeah I mean
there's so much in what you just shared
I mean this idea that you're this
aimless person who is perhaps on a not
so great trajectory who's lacking
self-esteem stumbles into this situation
where you found something that is truly
meaningful to you and then struggling to
be able to kind of Master your own
vehicle to do it is almost like an
existential crisis right like the stakes
are very high for you because you're
like I finally found this thing and now
I can't do it yeah like that's
terrifying yeah how do you resolve that
and to have the instinct to move towards
it rather than away from it yeah um is
almost like your own form of exposure
therapy like the only way I can like get
over this is to like destigmatize it by
upping the ante and putting forcing
myself to be in that situation and walk
through the fear to get to the other
side but to do that with a project of
such a high degree of difficulty like
yeah that's a that it's almost like an
instinctual thing that you came up with
that probably wasn't even on some level
conscious no it it definitely wasn't
conscious it just uh yeah I mean it was
kind of out of just desperation
[Music]
um it it lit like I don't have it in me
to like kill myself uh um but to sort of
give up would be
to it it would be to kill the the the
potential of any life that I actually
wanted to live um so to sort of give up
on that was so depressing so I think
that's the why I Found the courage in a
way to sort
of but then to have that muscle memory
around running towards something that
scares you I mean the question that I
asked you is like what you know if you
have a superpower what is it you
said you know how to grind but beneath
that it's that instinct to go towards
the scary thing that spills over into
every aspect of your life like if you
have that facility to not shy away from
those things then you're in this sort of
curious growth mindset way of
approaching your life good conversation
I actually haven't put the I hadn't put
those things together before uh yeah do
you find yourself doing that in other
areas of your life I mean you mentioned
that you have a relationship coach like
that's another like you have to seek out
like you have to be willing to go into
an uncomfortable place if you want to
have greater Intimacy in your
relationships if you want to advance
your career like every category the
solution is always moving towards the
thing that you wish you didn't have to
do
yeah and I think also like the great
things in life uh you get by putting in
a lot of work like it's so like the
relationship that I have you know with
the woman that I it it's we don't have
an easy relationship like we not long
ago we were throwing smoothies at each
other in public you
know um what's the where's the the the
differential like what do you where's
the tension like what's the what's the
issue that you run up me it's all her
fault you know it's
all tell it to the relationship yeah um
no we're both uh pretty stubborn people
and uh we both like to get it our way
and
um
and you know it's like sometimes it's
like fire fire meets fire and um and we
have a lot of passion and a lot of fun
um but find it hard to compromise and
it's
like we're going to figure it out and
we're going to have like a great big
life um and I and I but it's going to
you need a little outside intervention
keep it from going inside it's like yeah
it it's it's it's Mark it's MDMA it's h
you know it's a it's all of those things
uhhuh so psychedelics as part of that
protocol yeah for sure wow interesting
your mom's a therapist though right yeah
uh so it's not like therapy is a foreign
concept no but actually I haven't like
uh I've been trying to find a a good
therapist for myself uh I I
um I haven't done much therapy actually
um like I don't have like someone that I
talk on with on an individual level and
I I really need it um but uh I've
struggled finding someone um but yeah I
I think I grew up with my mom
definitely always instilled a way of
dealing with problems of you know
talking about problems like trying to
getting to the bottom of like what's
really going on like why why did you uh
you know throw this thing at the teacher
and uhuh yeah you were like a
hyperactive kid who was getting in
trouble yeah yeah I I was I was I think
I was a bit of a nightmare uhhuh and how
are things with Dad uh great now
uh uh we definitely had our uh Vol
volatile period and uh and also he was
you know raised in a
American way where um you know he got
his fair share of licks and uh you know
little bit of that translated into our
relationship and uh so Rocky during your
your uh turbulent adolesence yeah but
but you know it it was he he didn't know
how to deal with me he had a bad he
responded poorly and
um and he you know problems with his
anger controlling his
anger um and
uh yeah so but you know we we we got we
got through it and and you know when I
was I think in my early 20s we had a you
know this couple of really deep
conversations where you know he
apologized for some of the things that
he'd done and um and we have we have a
really beautiful and close relationship
now that's good how do you stay grounded
in and right sized with all the nonsense
and [__] that comes with the fame
part of what you
do yeah it's uh I I don't find it so
hard but
um you know I for me my my level of Fame
it's a little different in Sweden it can
get a little intense still even though
it's not as intense as it was you know
maybe five years
ago um for me it's it's really important
to have like really good people around
you that that you have real friendships
with I mean one big key is to not sort
of Play The Fame game and just hang out
with uh people that
you hang out with because how they
reflect on you do you have like a solid
group of friends here that aren't afraid
to tell you what's what yeah yeah yeah
you have to have that but also like I
don't need that really you know I I know
what's what and um um I think the I I I
had a period of my life where I I got
lost in that I I I I didn't realize it
until a few years ago but where I was
really concern I I was thinking a lot
about how I was perceived and and I was
really focused on how I was being
perceived and and I would even choose
friends on how they would sort of
reflect on me and like you know I I want
to be you know this guy you know
comes with a big crew and and uh and
then I think social media really doesn't
help
[Music]
um but actually this was like more
before that but um but yeah and and then
and I realized that you know like that
that is such
a that it's it's it's it's such a hollow
Pursuit you know that it's so it's so
it's so shallow to to look at life and
and people around you and and and and
and like so I sort of kind of figured
that out and and then
I you know
chose stayed away from all that kind of
stuff I I really haven't been chasing
any of of those sort of I had had it was
a couple of years when I I got a little
bit lost in it and and uh and I wanted
to be seen with you know other famous
people and uh you know I wanted to be
seen as someone that had a big crew that
you know rolling deepage with the whole
thing well I've noticed that you've
you've stepped back from social media I
mean you used to share videos and stuff
like that and I went to your Instagram
and there's just like one picture and
you're like you're like clearly you're
not participating in this anymore yeah
no that was a that was a great
realization um how bad it was for me um
and um and it just put my mind in the
wrong place for me uh social media just
just made me look at my life uh and made
me feel like I wasn't doing enough that
you know I should have all these other
things I should be doing this I should
be doing that H it just gave me a bunch
of anxiety I and I realized like I'm a
pretty happy person and uh and I was
just realizing
that the the anxiety that I was feeling
a lot of it was like coming from that
and then when I cut it out and when I
removed all social media um
man it really changed me um it talk more
about that yeah it
um first of all it's like it's so much
noise you just care and think about so
much [__] that's just it's like
gossip it's basically gossip you're
looking at other people's lives and and
seeing you know the fake version that
they're holding up to the world and uh
so it's it's a bunch of noise but then
it also like makes you feel shitty about
yourself and and it makes me feel like
man I should be doing this I should be
doing that why don't I have this why
don't I have friends like that oh you
know all these like stupid thoughts that
aren't based in reality and and and have
zero value but they're and this these
algorithms are just like kind of feeding
on insecurity and uh and as soon as I
cut it out like it just like all faded
away and and I you know I realized I
wasn't missing out on anything I mean I
miss out on some economic opportunities
of you know endorsement deals and stuff
like that but it's okay I I I make money
in other ways you're you're legit
established like it's really not
necessary for you I can imagine for
somebody who's coming up like this is
what you have to do and you have to be
active here and this is how you you know
unless you develop or cultivate some
level of following it's more difficult
to get cast or whatnot yeah you're kind
of past that so you don't have to worry
about that but on some level as an actor
it doesn't serve you for the public to
know so much about you right like your
job is to be subsumed into a character
and there's something about the Mystique
of like not knowing what this person's
private life is all about that I think
makes you more potent as a performer but
the incentives of our modern culture are
all moving in the other direction yeah
but when we look at somebody like
Quenton Tarantino or Daniel de Lewis
like we don't know anything about them
like they're incredible artists who go
away and disappear for however long and
then return to treat us all to their
gift and we celebrate them and it's all
we think and talk about culturally for a
moment because they're just in their art
you know like they don't have to
participate in this whatever you want to
call it like [__] [__] influencer
economy or whatever it is that's now
sort of part of it's sort of considered
part of the job for somebody like you so
do you have pressure like are there like
do you have team members who are like
you sure you want to do that like you
know no actually not like because my
team is so old school and and it's also
I think
because acting is
still pretty like shielded from it so
it's it's really you know of course
there are a bunch of these sort of stars
that have social media and you know they
have businesses and all this is sort of
intertwined and and the you
know you know the the rocks and the Ryan
Reynolds of the world that they're also
really good at it they're good at I mean
that feels they're Talent they it feels
natural for them to do it you know it
doesn't feel forced I mean Ryan is the
best you know because inred he's also
he's so he's so funny and it's like um
and he you could tell he's enjoying it
yeah yeah for me I was just I sucked at
it and uh and uh it just it just made me
just made me a more nervous insecure
person in general and
uh you know it's um you know if you if
you if you figure it out it's it's great
you know like there's there's if if you
enjoy it and and and you're good at it
uh you know it's great um I think
there's a lot of professional benefits
to it but for me
the the the benefits of staying off way
out the benefits I was getting from from
like trying to participate in that in
that whole game and um and then you know
even though I I sort of came up old
school in the way that you know just
what like you were saying that you want
to you want the audience to know as
little about you as as possible for then
it would be easier for them to suspend
their disbelief when they see you in in
a character I don't know if that
really matters that much
um but um I just don't want to I don't
want to play that game yeah um I'm sure
you get asked all the time by young
actors aspiring actors uh you know for
advice for a young artist that's at the
Inception of their career and they're
staring down the barrel of all the
obstacles and challenges that are
inevitably going to come in their
Direction what is the advice that you
give to somebody who has an artistic
aspiration don't have a plan
B um go all in this's no no other
alternative if you have a plan B as soon
as it gets tough yeah that will weed out
all the pretenders and you got and and
it's like
uh and and that's the scary part you
know but it it is a high risk High
reward Endeavor and and uh the
competition is so high there's so many
talented people that want it you know
there is a great life at the other end
of it uh with both artistic and monetary
reward so you know of course it's a it's
a really attractive uh best case outcome
but um if you want to get there it's
like just being talented is not going to
be enough um so you got to you got to
become I mean that's I'm just speaking
from what my my experience and uh uh my
experience say you have to become
obsessed um and uh and and you I think
you have to have a singular
Focus so uh so that means you know at
least for a part of your life being
prepared to sacrifice everything else
and um and just do that I think that's
the only way but you know if there if
there's another way that's great but but
that's that was sort of what worked for
me and when I've talked to other friends
that
uh that also have kind of gotten through
that sort of needle or been able to
thread that needle it's
uh yeah patience
persistence yeah and uh like I mean my
goal was when I started out I didn't
have like Hollywood in mind at all for
me success looked
like being an actor that you know is on
stage and sometimes gets to do like TV
and film you know in Sweden that was
like success but I also saw
that you have to be like top 10 top
15% of of the most successful cuz you I
remember I would go to you know in my
acting school you know the the the
National Theater School we'd have these
sort of parties and uh on the weekends
and then you know these actors would
come and hang out and you'd have these
sort of actors in their 40s 50s that
were not successful and they would hang
out at the these School
parties because they were hoping that
some theater director was going to show
up and they and and and they had this
you know this desperate stench
um and I saw that like that life um
because it's such a it's a tricky
profession where you're
always like looking for the next gig you
know there's you have to be comfortable
with a lot of uncertainty yeah very very
very uncomfort very comfortable with
that but but it's also you're always
like in Pursuit you know of of another
gig so if you're not if people are not
wanting
to if they're not asking you to dance
you know you're going to be standing
there on the dance floor and uh and if
you do that too long um that it does
something to you that's not good you
become insecure and and also because
it's so paired with who you are it's a
diff difficult uh profession to
be um unsuccessful in that also becomes
repellent to other people so it's a
cycle right yeah because the more
desperate you are the less people people
can read that energy and and there it
moves them in a direction opposite to
where you are yeah so I actually even
though I had this like this sort of
enormous
uh you know I felt this gratitude and
and I found this you know this passion
for this and and created a positive
identity for myself for the first time I
also saw this and and I actually vowed
to myself that if like if I'm not in the
top 10% of my generation after three
years I'm going to quit and I'm going to
do something
else uh and and I that's something I
told myself I don't know if I would have
yeah I was wondering like if if that had
occurred do you think you would have
done that cuz the other piece here that
I think is really important is that
lights on moment where you locked in and
you had that um Flow State experience
and the lights went on and you realize
like this was something that you could
fall in love with like that's not about
a career it's not about you know
paychecks or anything like that that's
about like something inside of you that
needed to be nourished and I think that
that is that speaks to like the
authenticity of the Journey that that
you went on like what does this mean
what is the why behind it I think
because the why is the only thing that's
going to sustain you especially if you
don't have a plan B that's true yeah I
think maybe that was the maybe that was
something that I was telling myself you
know to push myself
um um because it is it is a tricky thing
that you know but but but it is also
what
I to to to really like when when when
when people ask you know
me um like how how to do it and how to
um you know like like how do you how do
I get famous and how do I you know and
I'm like if you start in that end of of
f done then then you're then you're done
you have to fall in love with the craft
and and you have to become obsessed with
the craft and and continue to hone that
and then like the success will come um
[Music]
and I think I I I think that's it too
but but but it is it is a tricky
profession
to to uh to get stuck in you know if you
don't but but but I think the the the
only the only way is to go all out and
to and to just uh and and be
relentless the crazy thing about it is
that it's one of the only career paths
where your entire life could change
overnight like yeah audition audition
audition audition and then you know
pilot or whatever it is and like
everything changes so it's almost like
this weird slot machine I know not that
it's all about luck like obviously
there's preparation and talent there's a
lot that goes into it but I think that
that um sensibility that as dark as it
is or as hard as it is that it could
literally change tomorrow because you
got a call back yeah can keep people in
it maybe longer than should I don't know
like yeah but I I would imagine that you
can create an unhealthy relationship
with that fantasy of what a life could
be um that detracts from the craft piece
of it
yeah but the thing is that when I look
at like fellow actors and and people
that I've
known over the
years the people
it's very rare where you see someone
that is really
talented and also works really
hard that doesn't
eventually you know get their due that's
good to hear it's um because I would
have thought maybe it's not quite the
case like it's not a meritocracy like
I'm sure you know lots of super talented
performers who you know don't get the
break or the breaks don't come as easily
as perhaps fairness would say they
should I feel like a lot of the time it
you know and then of course success can
look in different ways
but the hard thing is to kind of stay
strong and to and to nourish your
confidence um while being rejected when
you're sort of in this audition game
yeah um
and I think you have to find other ways
to to to practice your craft to like
just do a play and um to get on stage
and and you know put something together
yourself where where you're actually
practicing your craft and and and where
you're where you can showcase it and and
not
just you know do these you know
100 auditions right right are you gon to
get back on the
stage man I've been saying that for so
long it's uh I was I've been actively
looking and I'm trying but it's uh
what's next what do you got coming
up well who knows it's uh this whole
this fall has been very frustrating with
strikes and projects moving it it kind
of the whole business got shook up so
I've had a couple of projects push and
fall apart and I'm supposed to go shoot
something I was supposed to go shoot
something in in January I think now it's
pushing to March and and yeah I I I had
my whole year booked up my my whole year
was kind of set and then things fell
apart and then I had it set again and so
I'm I'm not 100% sure yeah uh the things
that I have lined up are half of them
are sort of independent and and they're
you know more vulnerable to change yeah
well I'm a fan dude I appreciate you
coming to talk to me today um it's cool
to get a glimpse into your life thanks
man I I really enjoyed this conversation
this the is the longest uh is it we keep
going I got we can go for hours more if
you want no but it's a like I love I
love podcast and I love listening to to
podcast so it's uh it's really valuable
to to have these like long form
conversations and I
like I I got some insights into into
myself here this this was like GL give
you something to did I find my therapist
like I I'll serve that role for you um
and uh yeah come back when you have
something more to talk about I really
enjoy I really enjoy talking to you I
appreciate it so did I yeah so everybody
check out silent night I think it's
coming out on on uh on VOD like December
it's playing in theaters theat now Che
this isn't going up right away I think
but it will be it will be available for
streaming soon too I think I think on
the 19th of December it's available on
VOD and uh For All
Mankind there's so many things I want to
talk to you about didn't even get to go
deep into all of that so yeah I'd love
to have you back man if you'll come back
I'll be back peace dude bro PE
[Music]
cheers that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ral.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by BL
play Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt Trapper Patt
and Harry matthys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plance
namaste
[Music]
every